everyone knows the mega billionaires
behind the top corporations of the world
apple is steve jobs microsoft is bill
gates
amazon is the evil ball dude facebook is
mark zuckerberg
and tesla is elon musk contrastingly
only a small fraction of people know the
leaders by an alphabet
or google sergey brin and larry page
but why
[Music]
today google no doubt has the biggest
influence on each of our daily lives
aside from e-commerce they basically own
the entire internet
from mail and cloud storage to youtube
and google.com
not to mention android waymo and google
fiber
despite their vast impact larry page and
sergey brin
don't have a large fan base like steve
jobs or apple
nor are they widely credited for
revolutionizing the internet
at the same time though they also don't
have large hate trains like jeff bezos
and mark zuckerberg
though many people may dislike google
the feeling doesn't carry on to its
founders
as most people don't even know who they
are this leaves larry page
and sergey brin in a position where
they're not hated or
liked they're just there they're your
everyday mega billionaires who founded a
trillion dollar giant
so how did the genius founders of one of
the most influential companies
end up in such an underrated position
well
starting off neither larry page nor
sergey brin
have been the ceo of google for very
long when they started the company in
larry page was originally the ceo of the
company
but from the start both larry page and
sergey brin
knew that they weren't the charismatic
public ceo type
they were more of the innovative tech
people rather than businessmen similar
to elon musk
i hate to say it but if you've ever
heard larry page talk
you'd know that he's not very exciting
to listen to for the average person
he's full of great knowledge and new
ideas however
listening to him often just feels like
listening to a lecture
and i'm sure they know this as well as
they decide to act accordingly
instead of just pushing through with
um's here and there like elon musk
in 2001 the duo decided to hire a
businessman ceo
named eric schmidt as a result eric
schmidt would lead google to
all the public relations events during
the early days of google
from quarterly reports to acquisitions
though larry pidge
and sergey brin would play integral
roles behind the scenes
eric's name was the one that would make
it onto the newspaper
and to the public's ear most often this
situation would continue
for a full decade up until january of
2011.
at this point eric schmidt would step
aside to an advisory role
as executive chairman and larry page
would take the reins of the company
however two major issues would riddle
paige's leadership
and it wasn't that he was a bad ceo per
se
rather paige suffered from a health
condition
unfortunately in 2012 paige would be
struck by vocal cord paralysis
making it very difficult for him to talk
especially to large crowds
consequently he would begin skipping a
slew of earnings calls
and basically eliminated all public
speaking events understandably so
at the same time many of google
shareholders would start feeling that
larry page was often distracted by
various passion projects
such as google glass and the infamous
google island
google island was especially concerning
for investors
in 2013 larry page detailed how he would
like google to be run kind of like an
island
independent of regulation corporate
interests and of course
shareholders he believed that this would
be the best for pushing forward
innovation
and technological improvements but
though this may be admirable from an
outside perspective
this is extremely concerning for
shareholders at the same time
sergey brin would find himself within a
scandal in 2014
it came out that sergey brin was having
an affair with marketing manager
amanda rosenberg fortunately there were
no accusations of misconduct or anything
of that sort
but this doesn't look too good when
you're already married to someone else
and that someone else is the founder of
23andme
as you would guess this is when circuit
brent's image as a tony stark
similar to elon musk today basically
evaporated away
but since sergey brin was literally the
co-founder
and still retained large stakes within
the company he couldn't be kicked out
in the meantime larry page who likely
didn't want to take down his business
partner and friend
acted like the situation never happened
and would never publicly address it
following this event in august of 2015
both larry page and sergey brin would
basically just fall off the face of the
planet
larry page would announce that both of
them would step away from day-to-day
operations of google
and that they would become the ceo and
president of a holding company named
alphabet
alongside this sunder piche would assume
the role
of google ceo after this larry page
and sergey brin were still quite
involved with the running of google
as sunder piche was required to report
directly to page
and both of them held on to their voting
shares however
this transition effectively cut off all
public relations that either of them had
to participate in
this system would only last four years
until larry page and sergey brin would
completely step away
in december of 2019 making sandra pichei
the ceo
of alphabet as you can see neither larry
page
nor sergey brin served as a public ceo
for most of the company's life
in the early days it was eric schmidt
the two would start to play a more
public role in the early 2010s
but larry's health issues and sergey's
affair would quickly put a halt to this
endeavor
as a result the two never had much
publicity they didn't have iconic
product reveals like steve jobs or
elon musk nor did they participate in
infamous court hearings
but even more importantly i don't think
the two of them
cared to run a business they weren't
exactly interested in building up an
international conglomerate
and becoming full-time leaders slash
managers
rather they wanted to continue inventing
and innovating
in fact that's precisely what larry page
tried to do
during his time as ceo between 2011
and 2015 larry page would get google
much more heavily involved with
self-driving technology wearable
technology
smartphone lines and fiber internet and
as for sergey brin we all know his
dabble with the google glass
during their leadership it was said that
google was run more like a research
institution
as opposed to a multi-hundred billion
dollar company
moreover after stepping down as google
ceo
larry page would get more involved with
some rather interesting projects
in 2016 larry page began to concentrate
on flying cars
and he's not behind just one flying car
but
three of them which are the cora the
flyer
and opener evidently it seems like the
two
really just wanted to invent new things
and running an internet company
just wasn't that interesting to them
maybe they would have not just stuck
around
but have been leading voices in the
company if they were solely focused on
flying cars
and rockets and in such a scenario they
may have grown a fan base similar to
that
of elon musk but as this was not the
case
the two weren't at the forefront of
google's public relations
moving on the other major reason that
the founders of google
are relatively unknown is that the
average person
doesn't really care about google it's no
doubt a great service that's extremely
helpful
but it doesn't really get the average
person excited
the iphone gets people excited and
landing rockets gets people excited
but google not so much i mean a search
engine
and browser are great but it's not
necessarily
fun and cool this is the same case with
microsoft
facebook and amazon as well most people
don't find them exactly exciting don't
get me wrong here
these companies play an integral role in
many of our lives
from our operating system and our social
lives to one day prime delivery
with that being said though none of
these companies are particularly
exciting but one major difference
between these companies
and google is that their founders are
quite well known
so what could explain this well the
answer
is that all these guys are known for
their wealth
bill gates dominated the billionaires
list literally from the 1980s
till two years ago and he's still number
three
as for mark zuckerberg he was the next
harvard drop a billionaire
who reached billionaire status at a
record low age of 23 years old at the
time
and as for jeff bezos really the only
reason people even know him today
is because he's the richest person in
the world while amazon is notorious for
undercutting taxes
and paying employees low wages
contrastingly
though larry page and sergey brin are
extremely rich
they were never the richest in the world
nor were they the youngest on the list
so they weren't known for their wealth
either
at the end of the day most mega
billionaires are known for three major
reasons
which are being charismatic leaders
exciting contributions to society
and or extreme amounts of wealth to the
extent where they're the richest on the
list
or the youngest on the list and any
billionaire that doesn't conform to
these aspects
is often vastly unknown such is the case
with bernard arnold
and larry ellison but of course the two
most notable ones
are the computer geniuses from google
larry page
and sergey brin do you guys look up to
either of these pioneers
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think these two deserve some
more love
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one